♪ ♪
>> Tucker: ONE MORE THING
BEFORE WE GO TONIGHT.
SINCE THIS SHOW BEGAN A MOST
FOUR YEARS AGO I’VE REALLY TRIED
NOT TO TALK ABOUT MYSELF ON THE
AIR OR EVEN USE THE FIRST-PERSON
PRONOUN.
THE LAST THING THIS COUNTRY
NEEDS IS MORE NARCISSISM.
IT’S NOT VERY INTERESTING
ANYWAY.
PEOPLE EAT WHO USE THE WORD I A
LOT TENDER FOR EVERYONE BUT
THEMSELVES BUT TONIGHT WERE
GOING TO MAKE AN EXCEPTION TO
THAT RULE.
WE DON’T HAVE MUCH CHOICE.
LAST WEEK "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
BEGAN WORKING ON A STORY ABOUT
WHERE MY FAMILY AND I LIVE.
AS A MATTER OF JOURNALISM THERE
IS NO CONCEIVABLE JUSTIFICATION
FOR A STORY LIKE THAT.
THE PAPER IS NOT ALLEGING WE’VE
DONE ANYTHING WRONG AND WE
HAVEN’T WE PAY OUR TAXES.
WE LIKE OUR NEIGHBORS.
WE NEVER HAD A DISPUTE WITH
ANYONE.
SO WHY IS "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
DOING A STORY ON THE LOCATION OF
MY FAMILY’S HOUSE?
WELL, YOU KNOW WHY.
TO HURT US, TO INJURE MY WIFE
AND KIDS SO THAT I WILL SHUT UP
AND STOP DISAGREE WITH THEM.
THEY BELIEVE IN FORCE.
WE LEARN THAT.
TWO YEARS AGO, A LEFT-WING
JOURNALISM WAS PUBLICIZED OUR
HOME ADDRESS IN WASHINGTON, A
GROUP OF SCREAMING AND SCREAMING
ANTIFA LUNATIC SHOWED UP
WHILE I WAS AT WORK.
THEY VANDALIZED OUR HOME.
THEY THREATEN MY WIFE.
SHE CALLED 911 WHILE HIDING IN
THE CLOSET.
A FEW WEEKS LATER THEY SHOWED UP
AGAIN IN OUR HOUSE.
FOR THE NEXT YEAR, THEY SENT
LETTERS TO OUR HOME THREATENING
TO KILL US.
WE TRIED TO IGNORE IT AND FELT
COWARDLY TO SELL OUR HOME AND
LEAVE.
WE RAISED OUR KIDS THERE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND WE LOVED IT.
BUT IN THE END THAT’S WHAT WE
DID.
WE ARE FOUR CHILDREN.
IT WASN’T WORTH IT.
BUT "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
FOLLOWED US.
THE PAPER IS ASSIGNED A
POLITICAL ACTIVIST CALLED MARIE
CARPENTER TO WRITE A STORY ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE NOW.
THEY’VE HIRED A PHOTOGRAPHER
CALLED KRISTEN’S MINSKY TAKE
PICTURES.
THEIR STORY ABOUT WHERE WE LIVE
IS SLATED TO RUN THE PAPER THIS
WEEK.
EDITORS THERE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
WILL HAPPEN TO MY FAMILY WHEN IT
DOES RUN.
I CALLED THEM TODAY AND I TOLD
THEM.
BUT THEY DIDN’T CARE.
THEY HATE MY POLITICS.
THEY WANT THEY SHOW OFF THE AIR.
IF ONE OF MY CHILDREN GETS HURT
BECAUSE OF A STORY THE ROAD,
THEY WANT CONSIDERED COLLATERAL
DAMAGE.
THEY KNOW IT’S THE WHOLE POINT
OF THE EXERCISE.
TO INFLICT PAIN ON OUR FAMILY,
TERRORIZE US, CONTROL WE SAY.
THAT’S THE KIND OF PEOPLE THEY
ARE.
THEY WERE DENIED OF COURSE.
THEY WILL CLAIM IT’S JUST
JOURNALISM, JUST THE FACTS.
REALLY?
SO HOW WOULD MURRAY CARPENTER
AND HIS PHOTOGRAPHER TRISTEN’S
PENSKE FOR LIFE WE TOLD YOU
WHERE THEY LIVED, IF WE PUT
PICTURES OF THEIR HOMES ON THE
AIR?
WHAT IF WE PUBLICIZE THE HOME
ADDRESS OF EVERY ONE OF THE
SOULLESS ROBOT EDITORS OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHO
ASSIGNED AND MANAGE THIS
INCITEMENT TO VIOLENCE AGAINST
MY FAMILY.
WHAT ABOUT THE MEDIA EDITOR, JIM
WENT OFF.
WE COULD DO THAT.
WE KNOW THEY ARE.
WITH THAT QUALIFY AS JOURNALISM?
WE DOUBT THEY WOULD CONSIDER
JOURNALISM.